china está relajando su política cero
covid a marchas forzadas y lo está
haciendo además cuando los contagios no
dejan de crecer ocurrió ayer en one la
macrosidad del Sur que levantó los
confinamientos en la mitad de la ciudad
y ordenó el fin de los tes masivos ha
ocurrido también en chonchin y en
Shanghai ha ocurrido en Beijing la
capital donde las precauciones siempre
habían sido extremas ahora suma más de
5.000 casos es un nuevo récord hace unas
semanas habría bastado con la mitad de
los casos quizá un tercio para cerrar la
ciudad por completo ahora en cambio se
relajan los confinamientos los
contagiados asintomáticos podrán cumplir
la cuarentena en casa si prometen no
salir de ella De todas formas unos
dispositivos electrónicos en la puerta
fiscalizarán su cumplimiento y tan
importante como las medidas son los
discursos son chunland la vicepresidenta
ha sido la encargada del control de la
pandemia desde el inicio desde buján a
Shanghai o chonching allá donde los
veían que aterrizaba corrían a los
supermercados ante un inminente
confinamiento son por primera vez ha
variado el tono dice que con la menor
mortalidad de las nuevas variantes con
la mayor tasa de vacunación y con toda
la experiencia acumulada ha llegado el
momento de que el control de la pandemia
pase a una nueva fase también es
relevante que en el discurso ofrecido en
la agencia de noticias no se haya
mencionado ni una sola vez la política
de cero covid Ahora sí quizá porque
china se ha dado cuenta de que la última
variante es incontrolable quizá por las
protestas O quizá por ambas parece que
china se ha decidido a adelgazar
sustancialmente la política de cero
covid Después de tres años